foreign
what's up Celeste
hi Dr John thanks so much for taking my
call thank you for calling how in the
world are you
what's up so I have a question for you
um my question is what are some things
that I can do to help me handle living
in a place that I don't want to be and
I'll explain a little bit just move tell
me tell me what's going on if only for
that that easy okay
so we are full-time ministers my husband
and I and we've been living here for
eight years where's here Hide everything
yeah okay
and I've tried everything available to
me to learn the local language so group
classes private classes tutors online
lessons everything
I can barely string a few sentences
together even after all these years and
because of this language barrier
I feel isolated and vulnerable and
unable to add much value to the ministry
I feel like I'm becoming emotionally
unstable I Teeter between this is fine
taking care of my family is my Ministry
and full-blown rage at my husband for
keeping us here or just depression that
I'm a daily failure for being able to do
anything remotely useful
um so last year I decided I wanted to do
life someplace where I could speak the
language I speak Spanish and my husband
is Hispanic so we could tune Ministry in
any English or Spanish-speaking country
so I wanted to look at other options
But ultimately he doesn't feel called to
leave so I've chosen to stay here with
him
but every day is a struggle and it's
getting harder for me to find
contentment yeah
I want to challenge a little bit of your
language is that okay
yeah this is not about finding
contentment this is about survival
this is not about
um this is not you in Williamson County
Nashville Tennessee
one of the wealthiest counties on the
planet
trying to make it with four bathrooms
when you really want six
laughs
this is
[Music]
um
this is after eight years I've got to
get out of here
your body doesn't feel safe you don't
feel safe and
quite honestly the language thing I
think is indicative of a lot of other
stuff going on
um
can I ask you just a hard question and I
don't this is going to turn all
theological and I don't want it to but
it just can't not
um
I have run into recently more than than
usual more than I have in my life and
I've hung out with people of all
different religious groups for my whole
life
um and
the word quote unquote called I've been
called
it's just thrown around a lot
and more often than not in my experience
it has become a sentence used I have
been called to justify what I want to be
doing in a particular season and I
always have told people
okay
um
maybe you are called and maybe you
weren't but regardless of what it is
just go full into this thing and do it
and if it sounds like a crazy thing or
I'm being called away from my job just
quit your job like it doesn't need to
have this this existential weight to it
sometimes
um I had a great mentor of mine that
once told me
um
theologically speaking maybe you should
be more concerned with who you are
as you transition in and out of things
and as you are wherever it is you happen
to be then running around looking for
some Cosmic calling that's been hidden
from you so I tell you that to ask you
this question
you have a husband that's watching his
wife wither away before him
a wife who is blaming herself who is
hanging on and unable to breathe
and
when is
um what does calling look like
what's the feeling look what's he
looking for that would say okay now it's
time to go
um he wants a
does it come like a letter is an owl
going to land and start talking is it
gonna like have a vision what what is it
what's the thing
um
a clear
um a clear feeling I I don't know how to
say it but that God has told him that he
can leave here and also a confirmation
from our pastors
so that's would suggest that he has
placed you third
yeah
behind his feelings behind
um
a group of men I'm assuming
um it's a couple a couple who doesn't
want who would suggest we don't want him
as an employee and maybe I'm wrong but I
can't imagine the line to go serving
Azerbaijan is super long
and so they don't want to lose an
employee and then his dying wife
comes third
yeah
I've been around
the Christian Bible my whole life and I
don't know I haven't read read that
order yet
I I have high concern about people who
are waiting for quote unquote feelings
from God
foreign
yeah I I understand that and
um last year
I I tried
my best to
to work through uh the system that we
have created for ourselves and uh the
language is very important you don't say
I feel
or it's hard or I'm struggling he's
saying let's look at options let's see
if we can transition wait why why why
did y'all create a structure that
divorces
one of the most one of your body's most
important signaling systems
um
uh I don't know I I feel that is the way
our our church does things and our
pastors do things
we don't rely on our feelings because
our feelings are unreliable except your
husband's waiting for a feeling to know
what to do next
it doesn't make any sense
um it sounds like there is some high
high control
and some High High
um
restriction of autonomy you will submit
to us because we are your leaders and we
know more about what
the spirit or whatever is telling you
and it's more important than your
depression it's more important about
your thoughts that you would rather not
be here at all than be here where you
happen to be the thoughts you're having
about just running away and leaving your
husband and your family so that you can
breathe all those things
we'll tell you we'll tell you how to
feel later
and with all due respect Celeste that's
dangerous dangerous ground
and I hate to be telling you this
because I know you already know all this
I want you to first and foremost know
you're not crazy okay you're not crazy
this situation sounds Bonkers if any one
of your pastors wants to call me I'm
happy to have them on my show and we can
have it out and if I'm wrong I'm happy
to be wrong this sounds dangerous to be
honest with you
um
so the real question here is this you
can't do anything about what the pastors
think what they believe what they feel
you honestly can't do anything about
what your husband thinks or feels or
believes because he has chosen
to wait for indigestion or for his heart
to beat faster or whatever feeling he
thinks he's gonna feel
um
and he's chosen to wait for a couple to
tell him what he and his wife are
allowed to do with their lives
and so the only person you can control
in this situation is you your thoughts
and your actions
and so my challenge to you is
are you in a position
to
um find safety in places there and
Azerbaijan and when I say safety I mean
join a dancing class maybe you can't
speak the language but we're going to
get integrated and I'm sure you've tried
all this stuff
um join a whatever group or this group
or that group or is it time to begin to
say hey in 365 days
I'm leaving and going back to the States
you get to choose whether you come with
me
I have thought about that
I don't I don't know if I should do that
if that's the right thing to do
um to do that to him
I can tell you that ends his whole world
what what part of his world do you play
uh we we came through this thing
together I was I was totally on board we
were okay on the same track and things
have just changed over the years and
that's okay
my wife married a guy who was going to
be a heavy metal singer that didn't work
out then she was married to a guy who's
going to be a college President thus far
she's married to a YouTuber and a
podcaster right things change and I
Married an extraordinary Elementary
School teacher who became a world-class
research college professor and she
recently got her master Gardener's
license and now has created like a
jungle in my backyard and it's
incredible
you know what she's planted every every
living plant that has ever existed is in
my in the gardens in the backyard we've
become different people because our
lives changed
and with you if
you are trying to compress yourself to
such a degree
that even if you do survive this
literally
you will have set a forest fire you will
have done a control burn on the things
that makes the last Celeste inside
burn them to the ground
so that if y'all end up in Spain or
Venezuela or back in the States
you'll just be a shell of who you once
were and I don't think that's fair to
you I don't think that's fair to your
husband I don't think that's fair to
your kids I don't think that's fair to
the people you're serving you're worth
more than that Celeste
and I'm telling you this as a husband at
least for me
I would much rather have a different job
and a whole wife than the other way
around
and I challenge any husband
any husband
worth their salt to flip that equation
on me
no bro I'd rather have a great job and
feel the right feelings in my guts and
have my wife just slowly wither away
that's insane
insane
so here's what I want you to do
um I also know this I know there are
cultural implications I know there are
safety implications I know there are
financial implications there's a lot
here and it is easy for me as a 200
pound six foot male just to start
cranking things out you need to do this
you need to do this
there's a lot of scary things between
you and just walking the streets of St
Louis right
yeah a lot I know that okay
I want you to do the hard work of
writing down maybe for the first time
here's what I want
and here's what I need
what I need for me to feel safe what I
need from you me to feel whole what I
need for me to to continue in this
marriage
here's what I want from me here's what I
want for my kids
here's what I want for my marriage
and I want you to sit with that for a
bit
and if you're spiritually LED pray over
that for a bit
and then from those needs and from those
wants will come some pretty clear
boundaries
Christmas 2023
I am moving
with all of my heart and soul I hope you
move with me
and maybe God's speaking through me
husband
this is the message you were looking for
ta-da
it just looks like Celeste not
indigestion whatever feeling you think
is coming
it doesn't have to be Christmas it
doesn't have it can be whenever
um
but I want you to spend some time with
you and if possible
not the couple that
I guess you all work for but
find a couple of women who maybe are
former
um missionaries
some women who have been where you have
been and have come out on the other side
that you are able to say
um I need some help I'm not okay or how
did you handle this
and you're going to feel at the
beginning like you're betraying your
husband and private family secrets and
this couple that that runs y'all's life
is gonna wake we keep family stuff
internal not anymore because you're
you're the language you're using is one
of someone who is on a trajectory that
makes me uncomfortable
as a guy who's done funeral services as
a guy who's done Memorial Services as a
guy who has sat with people who are
thinking about hurting themselves you're
a guy who sat with people who have just
left their marriages because they just
can't your trajectory doesn't feel good
and rightfully so
but I want you to get some people
outside of this toxic Circle and begin
to say hey I need some help I need some
help what do you think about this am I
crazy what was an Avenue out what's a
path like what are conversation starters
what are some things that I can do over
the next two months five months six
months a year or whatever my boundaries
are going to be
um
but just from what you're telling me
this it sounds like you're done Beyond
done
and now as you're unable to have any
kind of power control over your external
situation you're beginning to set fire
to what's inside
and that makes me nervous for you and
you you gotta hear me say you're worth
more than that
anytime you want to call Celeste
um we're here
and if you want to tell that couple
that's uh hasn't got their feelings yet
tell him give me a shout